let's talk a little bit about another
hypocrisy
which is that on fox news they have had
all of these different news anchors
tucker carlson
laura ingraham and all of these are you
you you know the you know the crew
bemoaning
and denouncing joe biden's vaccine
requirements
for big businesses
as tyrannical
as authoritarian
as illegal as unconstitutional
uh despite not being any of those things
when fox news has had an actual stricter
policy
on masking on testing and on vaccines
which the white house is now praising
this this is actually uh uh unbelievable
the white house is now praising fox for
having a stricter version
of biden's vaccine or test mandate
despite bashing the policy on air
the white house praised one of its top
media critics fox news for announcing an
even stricter vaccine or test mandate
than the administration's new federal
policy for employers
fox announced tuesday it will soon roll
out daily covid testing for unvaccinated
employees remember biden's proposal
was
vaccinated or weekly testing fox is
going to do vaccinated or daily testing
if you've not revealed your vaccination
status to the company they've asked
employees to submit vaccination status
and revealed 90 percent of its employees
confirmed they had been immunized
against the virus think about that
if the country
was as vaccinated as fox news employees
things would be going way better right
now denmark which is 75 vaccinated which
is still almost 50 percent greater than
us
um denmark is essentially wide open with
declining cases
fox is 90 vaccinated
if the country was as vaccinated as fox
news which on air criticizes vaccine
requirements we would be in a really
good position right now um as the
article says last week biden announced
all employers with more than 100
employees must mandate vaccines or
weekly testing fox previously required
certain essential employees to undergo
regular testing the white house urged
fox to inform its audience about the
effectiveness of such policies white
house spokesperson said tuesday today's
news from fox follows a trend we're
seeing across the country vaccination
and testing requirements work we're glad
they've stepped up to protect their
workforce and strengthen the economy we
encourage them to convey to their
audience that these types of practices
will protect their employees communities
and the economy this is in addition to
fox's policy
that only vaccinated employees can
remove masks in some settings all
employees must be masked in confined
indoor settings think about that
biden rolls out a policy which is if you
have 100 employees
you've got to vaccinate or you've got a
test weekly no mandated masking for the
unvaccinated
foxes on
talent
goes on and says this is tyrannical this
is not freedom this is un-american this
must be stopped this could be against
the law
and yet behind the scenes
fox news has the same vaccinator test
requirement except at fox it's not a
weekly test it's a daily test if you're
unvaccinated and in addition to that in
some settings if you're unvaccinated you
have to keep wearing a mask it is much
stricter at fox news than what fox's own
on-air talent decries as tyrannical
government oppression
uh as outlined by joe biden in his
proposal so why hasn't tucker carlson
resigned to protest these dystopian
policies uh meanwhile he's on air saying
hey you know what we we've gotta we've
gotta investigate we've gotta fly to
trinidad to interview nicki minaj's
cousin's friend whose testicles swelled
after getting the evil vaccine and yet
he's part of a company with a stricter
requirement than what joe biden has laid
out and you know the reason why
it's all disingenuous garbage tucker
makes a ton of money at fox news it's
really that simple
but he makes the money at fox off of an
audience whose education and finances
are different than his
the messaging on his show isn't for
people like him for people in his tax
bracket with the amount of sort of
market power that he has
as a well-paid and and um uh
uh highly rated fox news host
uh it's for people who make a lot less
money and have a lot less market power
in dealing with their employers
who actually are at much greater risk if
they show up and they say what you guys
are doing is tyrannical tucker told me
on fox news so it's all a setup for
tucker's audience to just blame the left
blame the left for all of it uh and you
don't you know the all of the bad things
that are happening are because of
democrats and we should oppose all of it
even though tucker himself is implicitly
accepting it by continuing to work at
fox news under a stricter mandate than
that which joe biden proposed last week
so it's pathetic
and uh we will keep calling it out
but at the end of the day if people
don't realize that this is all a ruse
they are going to keep getting
bamboozled by it and saying no tucker
told me that this is tyrannical tucker
told me that this is bad
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter deepakman one of our
sponsors is sheath underwear it is the
hottest part of the year right now if
you're a guy who wears traditional
underwear
you know about the sticking and the
rubbing and the chafing
not something you have to worry about
with sheath underwear which is designed
with multiple ergonomic compartments in
the front
which prevent skin on skin contact
keeping everything separate dry cool and
comfortable
sheath actually just re-release two
limited edition styles the flower of
life
featuring a stylish enamoring flower
pattern and bold geometric waistband the
other limited edition style is the mesh
airflow specially designed to be
lightweight and promote extra coolness
and breathability sheath underwear was
designed by an iraq war veteran who was
looking for a way to keep himself dry
and comfortable in the hot desert and
the underwear he developed ended up
being perfect for just about any context
in everyday use sheath underwear is
giving my viewers 20 off when you go to
sheath underwear dot com slash pacman
and use the promo code pacman